je suis Carole au RSA depuis un an et
demi mon conseiller Pôle Emploi me
propose un emploi à temps partiel en
tant que vendeuse dans un magasin de
prêt-à-porter il me présente un nouveau
dispositif r+, l'allocation d'insertion
et de retour à l'emploi je signe mon
contrat de travail et le contrat R+ avec
un conseiller d'insertion du département
sur toute la période où je travaille à
temps partiel R+ maintient le niveau de
mes allocations et s'ajoute à mes
revenus d'activité avec l'accompagnement
de mon conseiller d'insertion mon
objectif est d'atteindre un SMIC à temps
plein R+ l'activité en toute sécurité
plus d'informations sur www département
9 7 4.fr